regresa la atención al capitolio esta
vez por cuenta de un viejo debate que ha
vuelto a la primera plana el porte de
mascarillas los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades recomiendan
portarlas
incluso a aquellos que han sido
vacunados cuando se encuentran en
espacios cerrados la mayoría demócrata
de la cámara baja impuso el uso de las
mascarillas en el recinto una decisión
de rechazada por los republicanos
estamos vacunados no somos un poco de
contagio pero nos obligan a llevar
mascarilla no en el senado pero si en la
cámara esto se trata de un mayor control
esto es sólo el comienzo porque las
escuelas van a volver a funcionar y las
van a cerrar de nuevo y se trata de
control base monos en la ciencia los
comentarios del líder de la minoría
republicana de la cámara y llevaron a
nancy pelosi a referirse a él como un
imbécil según los centros de control y
prevención de enfermedades el 67 por
ciento de los condados de eeuu tienen
altas tasas de transmisión del virus lo
que ha llevado al presidente by the end
a insistir en la necesidad de la
vacunación
o descartar imponer que las inyecciones
sean obligatorias para empleados
federales algunos estados se han
adelantado como por ejemplo nueva york
que requerirá vacunas a los empleados
estatales además de ofrecer incentivos a
los ciudadanos when you get your first
those al recibir la primera dosis contra
el coronavirus taxi
al recibir la primera dosis recibirá un
incentivo de 100 dólares one hundred
down 100 dólares para cualquier
neoyorquino que acuda a un centro de la
ciudad para vacunarse y packs de más de
160 millones de personas han sido
completamente vacunadas en eeuu aunque
la vacunación sigue siendo eficaz contra
la variante delta nuevos datos
científicos indican que incluso los
individuos vacunados pueden ser
contagiosos